yesterday's protests were uh spontaneous
expressions of people who were exhausted
with the cuban government's economic
mismanagement well
no they're being very very they're
marching with the american flag
the cuban people do not wish to live
under the boot heel
of this regime any longer part of what
what drives the the sort of obama-esque
view of how cuba ought to be treated as
a particular view of the united states
and its values
there's a view that obama made
mainstream on the left and it had been
mainstream back in the 70s but kind of
fell out of favor with the rise of the
reagan era
which was that america was inherently
bad america's involvement in vietnam was
bad america's involvement in iraq was
bad
and america's involvement in cuba is bad
america is the nefarious force in the
world and the real problems that
americans need to face down are the
problems here at home
america doesn't have anything to say
about what happens in the rest of the
world because after all america is just
too perverse america is just too
wrong-headed
america is just too much of a problem so
this has led as i say
to this conflict inside the bible
administration on the one hand you have
joe biden
who is speaking sort of classical
democrat language from the jfk days
talking about how the people of the
united states stand firmly with the
people of cuba here was
the president of the united states
saying the right thing with regard to
cuba yesterday
cuba people demanding their freedom
from an authoritarian regime and i don't
think we've seen anything
like this protest in
a long long time if quite frankly ever
the united states stands firmly with the
people of cuba
as they assert their universal rights
and we call on the government
government cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people of cuba okay this is the
right statement right credit where
credit is due joe biden is saying the
right thing the problem is
his administration immediately started
trying to walk a lot of this stuff back
so first they said that the statement
that he put out
was written for him right not by him for
him
then gensake tried to downplay what was
happening in cuba
as merely a sort of spontaneous eruption
at the lack of economic opportunity and
the problems with regard to vaccine
distribution in cuba this is not true
it is not true i've been talking to
cuban dissidents for the last several
weeks
they were planning this sort of stuff
for weeks on end there was a burgeoning
democratic movement in cuba i knew weeks
ago that people were going to get out in
the streets people in cuba knew weeks
ago that they were going to get out into
the streets
this is not just about the way the cuban
regime is handling its problems right
now
and this again is a sort of pattern in
the way the democrats view the world
when a bad thing happens out there they
like to say not that it's a pattern that
springs
from the nefarious evil of underlying
institutions
right when it was benghazi it wasn't the
nefarious evil of isis that was to blame
or america's soft stance with regard to
security in places like libya that was
to blame
no it was just a spontaneous eruption of
upset
over a random youtube video and now
according to gensaki what's going on in
cuba is a spontaneous eruption
thanks to economic dislocation that is
untrue it is not
true the cuban people do not wish to
live under the
boot heel of this regime any longer and
downplaying what is happening in cuba
has some sort of like
spontaneous reaction to current economic
circumstance ignores the fact
that a huge percentage of south
florida's population are cuban
expatriates who fled from the country
specifically
because it is an oppressive hell hole
okay here is gensake sort of downplaying
the cause that people are fighting and
now being imprisoned and probably dying
for in cuba
there's every indication that
yesterday's protests were
spontaneous expressions of people who
were exhausted with the cuban
government's economic mismanagement
and repression and those these are
protests inspired by the harsh reality
of everyday life
in cuba not people uh in another country
i'm saying that because i think there
have been a range of accusations out
there as you well know
okay and then she says well you know it
was really the lack of vaccines that
caused all this
trying to downplay this as lack of
vaccines or spontaneous eruptions over
the economy
ignores the fact there have been people
on the ground planning this sort of
stuff for decades fighting this sort of
stuff for decades not just in cuba but
also
outside of cuba we've talked to them on
the program here's shinsaki again
taking the sort of obama-esque approach
here obviously one of the issues
that uh the uh that protesters are
justifiably out there in the streets uh
processing about is
hunger is lack of access to vaccines etc
but we are continuing to provide a range
of assistance which we will continue to
do
okay now here's the problem one of the
big problems is not just the moral
problem
with sort of making light of the
underlying evil of the cuban regime
the bigger problem is that the solution
that would seem to be called for by
diagnosis of the problem as just
coveted vaccines or lack of economic
opportunity is you ship some money in
some vaccines over there
i just throw them some cash throw them
throw them into some vaccines and then
call it a day
that would seem to be the dictated
solution that of course is not a
solution
the solution is the fault of the regime
the united states
can't necessarily effectuate that from
the outside we certainly can do a whole
hell of a lot more
than simply talk about how you know they
may have botched this one
you know peter ducey from fox news was
back in the white house press room and
uh asking the tough questions so he said
um yeah so you guys keep saying it's
about vaccines in the economy i've
noticed that they are not shouting
vaccines
and the economy they are shouting
freedom and enough here's peter
ducey grilling jensaki when these
protesters are
yelling freedom and enough there are
people within the administration who
think they're
saying freedom from rising covert cases
again i would say that when people are
out there in the streets protesting and
complaining about the lack of access to
uh economic uh prosperity to
the medical supplies they need to a life
they deserve to live
that can take on a range of meetings
there's a global pandemic right now
most people in that country don't have
access to vaccines that certainly is
something we'd love to help with
it could take on a range of meanings
well no they're being very very
they're marching with the american flag
and this is the point
this is where it gets very uncomfortable
for jen saki and the biden
administration again they're of divided
mind on the one hand
joe biden wants to say that he's a
patriot who loves the american flag
on the other hand joe biden refuses to
say to his left flank that they are
doing something wrong
in burning the american flag or stomping
on the american flag or kneeling for the
american flag and this makes for a very
uncomfortable situation for them when
cuba breaks out like this because when
people of cuba are flying the american
flag
and saying we want our freedom and
people on joe biden's left are saying
america shouldn't get involved because
america is the problem america is bad
the true authoritarian threat
is not from actual authoritarians the
true authoritarian threat is here at
home
it puts joe biden in the middle of a
vice he's not willing to stand up to his
left and he's not willing to stand up
for his own principles
here was jen saki having a tough time
explaining why dissenters in cuba are
even flying the american flag now for
any normal person
any normal american this is a very easy
answer the reason that cuban dissenters
cuban patriots are flying the american
flag and not just the cuban flag
is because america stands for liberty
because the declaration of independence
promulgates principles that are
universal in nature because the united
states has been a beacon of hope for
oppressed people around the world
for centuries at this point that is a
very simple answer
and and yes it is wrong for americans to
disdain their own flag there's something
deeply ungrateful and wrong with it yes
they have a right to do it but you
already do lots of stuff in america
that's incredibly dumb and wrong-headed
you have a right in the united states of
america to write on your own
forehead that would be a that'd be a
stupid thing to do
just because you have a right to do
something doesn't mean you ought to do
it or that you are right to do it
but the bite administration does not
have the stones to simply tell its own
left you guys are wrong on this sort of
stuff so
this leads to the uncomfortable
realization that gensake
can't even just acknowledge the
realities which is that the cuban
dissenters are right and a lot of
americans are wrong
does the administration support
international protesters flying the
american flag and what message
do you have to americans who are wary of
flying it here in the u.s
well i would say first the the president
certainly
values and respects uh the uh the uh
symbol of the american flag he's someone
who
certainly uh waves it outside of his uh
house or
does in delaware and and other places
where he's lived throughout his time uh
but he also believes that people have
the right to peaceful protests and he
thinks both can be true
well both are true of right to peaceful
protest and also the people who are
protesting
by disdaining the american flag are
morons they're world historical idiots
both of those things can be true but she
won't say that she won't say that
instead
she'll downplay the cuban protest as
sort of a situational
problem she will ignore the fact that it
is idiotic to protest the beacon that is
the united states
and by the way the more that the united
states refuses to stand up for itself as
a beacon of freedom
the less that american flag actually
means to people around the world you
want to see the center stop flying the
american flag please keep promulgating
policy
like this in just one second we'll get
to the folks that democrats are really
threatened by the folks that they really
are worried about
it's not cuban authoritarians it is not
the chinese regime that just stomped all
over hong kong it's not the iranian
terrorists who run the country
no they're worried about you really they
are worried about you anybody who is
conservative anybody who's sent her
right anybody who's sent her all of you
people are the people who they are
worried about you're the true
authoritarian threat
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic i'd
watch that make it happen gang